well thank you Rocky that looks like so
much fun I need one of those drinks well
the Copa room at the Tuscany is the
place to be on Sunday nights because
Kelly Clinton has a new residency called
the sit-in and she is here with us today
to tell us all about it Kelly so great
to see you hello so good to see you too
well I'm so excited for you and this new
show but before we get to that before we
started this interview I said how do
your hair it's always so bouncy right is
it bouncy it is you're just always here
you're still all you're bouncy okay I
just wake up in the morning and there it
is like this oh my goodness it takes
forever but not hot rolls your husband
hot rollers I miss hot rollers I listen
too makes me think of late 70s early 70s
Farrah Fawcett yeah we're going totally
in another Direction aren't we anyway
but you know
this you know big roller not rollers but
anyway hot curling iron move on
straightening irons hairspray hours time
blow drying Tuscany
what you look great and you always sound
great tell us about this show we're
talking about the Tuscany is so intimate
and special I just love the vibe there
tell us about the new residents I know I
remember when I first went there I was
working in the Piazza for a while a few
years ago and it is it's so much fun it
and it's got wonderful restaurants and
there's a showroom there and it's called
The Copper room and there are many shows
in the room dick Feeney is a producer
and he because the rat pack is back in
there and also a show called juman room
so but the only night that it wasn't
taken was the Sunday night and I said
what a great night for entertainment
there's not a lot of shows going on on
Sunday nights so we started last week
and it is a blast well it looks like fun
we're seeing some video here you're
always having fun on stage standing
around in your Sparkles and you're gonna
have that's your husband that's right we
should explain that's Clint Holmes and
that's actually one of his shows a few
weeks ago and uh but he literally last
night got up on stage at the sit-in at
the Copa room so you know he always says
I have to come or my wife will kill me
well good he shows up and supports and
he's just one of the many people you're
kind of bringing in Surprise guests
every weekend right that's what it is
it's a variety show it's comedy music
and fun we have comedians um actually
next week next Sunday we have a
gentleman named John D Dominico yeah and
I don't know if you know yeah you just
Impressions and he does Trump he does
the Mike Myers the yeah he's Dr Evil
he's so great so he's a part of the show
and then we have Elisa fiorillo who I
know you've met her before she's great
entertainers great recording artist and
Marco two was there last night we've got
a young man who's out up for the voice
right now Angelo was on last night great
singers great musicians and and it's
just a wonderful room we've got to come
oh this is so much fun Kelly we are so
excited for you and you um you're
performing at the Copa room not the
place to be also with some special
performances at the Sterling Club too so
check her out she's all over the city
but the information is on your screen
the sit in with Hillary Clinton she's
performing Sundays at 7 30 p.m again
that is at the Copa room inside the
Tuscany Suites and casino thanks